au coeur de la bresse bourguignonne
placer parmi les 100 plus beaux détours
de france loin doit sa renommée à son
patrimoine architectural et historique
mais aussi à son fameux marché du lundi
depuis le moyen âge ici c'est plus
qu'une tradition une véritable
institution dont la ville peut
s'enorgueillir sauf peut-être l'hiver
dernier ont regardé c'était il ya tout
juste un an le marché encore dieu donné
par l'allée des andouillettes sont pas
la halle marchande là n'est pas là enfin
il ya dans la moitié qui sont pour la
automatiquement habituellement ici c'est
bondé de monde et on se retrouve avec
une murale un marché vide
le maire n'en veut plus il faut dire
qu'on est bien loin des 270 tentes
présentes durant l'été sur la place du
marché ou dans la grande rue les clients
se sentent parfois un peu seul c'est
vrai qu'il est vilain 1 c'est plus les
marchés de
d'entre vous les miroirs ému à personne
dommage
il prend depuis le marché du lundi a
repris des couleurs
les allées du centre-ville sont bondés
nous y avons rencontré le maire de loix
frédéric bouchet un peu moins désespérée
de l'an dernier bonjour madame vous
alors vous avez retrouvé le sourire
comment ça commence à reprendre un peu
le sourire là comme vous pouvez le voir
on a quand même un peu de monde
le soleil et la voilà donc un peu moins
c'est ainsi que répondre un puits square
pour notre marché
oui c'est pas tout à fait ce qu'on a vu
l'année dernière c'était pas du tout la
même conjoncture c'est vrai que l'année
dernière on était frappé par le mauvais
temps en trop il y avait peut-être un
manque de mobilisation de la part de
disposant et l'on retrouve qu'avec les
mesures protectrices on retrouve un
petit peu plus de responsabilités un peu
plus de deux volontés algérie des
mesures contre l'absentéisme des
commerçants qui pouvait être sanctionnée
rappelez-nous un petit peu car c'est une
mesure qui existe déjà et là aujourd'hui
on l'a remis en place parce que c'était
il fallait appliquer cette règle une
règle qu'il est peut-être utile de
rappeler en cas de fort absentéisme un
avertissement sera adressé aux
commerçants et au delà de 10 absence la
perte de l'abonnement sera prononcé non
n'allez pas normal parce que il ya des
gens qui aimeraient avoir des places au
marché
et s'il ya des gens qui ne viennent pas
ça pourrait libérer de la place à
d'autres personnes
mercredi la place de quelqu'un comme ça
qui viennent depuis 30 ans ou 25 ans
même dix ans non c'est pas c'est notre
gagne pain avant tout sans justificatifs
d'absence la punition pourrait donc
tomber pour les commerçants pour la
mairie le prix à payer pour garder un
marché à tresques
[Musique]
finalement depuis un an un seul
commerçant du marché de louhans s'est vu
retirer son abonnement
mais pour frédéric bouchet pas de doute
s'il ya moins d'absents cet hiver c'est
bien grâce aux mesures prises par la
mairie ça vraiment remobiliser les
troupes à ça les responsabilités je vous
en remercie parce qu'ils en ont vraiment
pris conscience
ils ont vu que un marché sans eux c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas tenable
douze mois plus tard derrière les étals
les sanctions contre l'absentéisme au
continue pourtant de faire polémique
c'est ça qu'il faut être fier le marché
pour que les gens continuent à venir dès
lundi mais de nombre d'absences à dix ça
fait d'absence par an à peine 900 par
mois
il ya des forains qui font des foires
mensuelles qui tombe le lundi comme par
exemple le renard et ses 12 à 10 par an
pour des gens qui sont là depuis
nombreuses années c'est quand même abusé
dix absents parce que c'est vite fait
quand il ya la tempête l'année dernière
vous n'êtes pas si faisait très mauvais
conte souvient il vient un temps
épouvantable
donc nous ce qu'ils voyaient pas c'est
qu'on casse notre matériel dans
l'alimentaire on
jour intel qui vient mais ceux qui font
de la confection quand il fait vraiment
mauvais qui fait très froid les gens
n'ont pas envie d'essayer sur le marché
et on comprend très bien que les gens
viennent pas déballer un vrai problème
pour ce marché qui compte parmi les cinq
plus grands de france
il attire chaque lundi entre dix et
quinze mille personnes
une fréquentation multipliée par deux en
étaient là c'est un enjeu majeur parce
que c'est un enjeu économique terrible
puisque vous avez un peu tout le milieu
agricole qui se retrouvent sur sept sur
lille et ça va bien au delà je prends
les boulangers le jour il y avait moins
de fréquentation perdais l'avant du pain
les restaurateurs disons tout ce milieu
économique qu'il y autour du marché
c'est quelque chose de deux importants
pour notre ville parce que ça c'est le
fleuron
moi je dis souvent c'est le marché de
louhans c'est un peu comme la tour
eiffel à paris
c'est indissociable il faut à un moment
donné que les gens puissent se
raccrochait quelque chose qui existe
so terroir et puis là c'est vraiment le
côté rural est représenté par me
trancher ça fait plus de 800 ans que ça
dure et ça doit continuer longtemps
encore là à deux débats
tout le monde est d'accord